so that's the big new idea today I'm
going to give you just two more examples
of doing this conversion and working
from one to another and then we're going
to go okay how does it end yeah okay let
me do another one
how about long base 5 of 25 what's that
going to be equal to how long if you're
growing at five times if you're
quintuple Inge each step of the way how
long would it take you to get to 25 -
another way of thinking about it is what
power do I have to raise this to to get
to that then the answer is five squared
which means what exponential equation
would you write that goes with this guy
five squared is 25 okay that's what's
your complicated alright how about I'm
going over here
whoopsie-daisy I'm going to pick one of
the ones that they've given us oh this
is a bit of a this is a chocolate as a
Harlem okay this is more challenging hmm
[Music]
have a look this is more challenging
because look that looks course that's
not even a whole number okay but you
think about this just like I said over
here this number here 4 is like what
power do I have to raise 3 to to get 81
well 3 to the power 4 is 81 what power
do I have to raise 5 to to get 25 and
the answer is 5 squared will give me 25
so what power do I have to raise that to
to get this any takers
yeah well you recommended okay let's try
this out let's just give this a go
because we'll learn something right the
square root of 3 if I raise it to the
power of 4 where learn something right
this is root 3 Times root 3 Times root 3
Times root 3 isn't it
so this is certainly getting us closer
it's on the way isn't it
what's that equal to just the first two
that's x3 well that'd be also three so
this gets us to nine that's close to
what we want how many more times do I
have to do it to get to there instead of
doing it four times I should do it six
times should know that's going to be six
times that's going to be 27 okay
another way you can confirm that by the
way is in index notation you can write
root three country without a square root
sign how would you write if index
notation three to the power of one the
square root of three do you remember
this is tricky
fractional indices this is three to the
power of 1/2 3 to the power of 1/2 if
I'm raising that to the power of six
what do I do with those indices what
happens to them
yeah they multiply across so this is 3
cubed which is 27 like we said okay so
therefore let me say it again and in
fact I'll even write it I'll then write
it and maybe you want to write it as
well because such a helpful lens for
looking at this what power must I raise
unless you root 3/2 so that the answer
is what one that looks I want I 127
right question mark and we've just found
out the power that we want is 6 Duncan
okay so this is a weird new idea I
haven't explained yet why looking at
things from this perspective rather than
this perspective is going to be useful
that is something we will explore in the
coming days okay